8000 c'est le nombre de tweei rappelés
en Europe par le constructeur Renault
dont le centre de recherche est implanté
à guyancour en cause une fuite du
liquide de frein sur certains de ces
quadricycles électriques et un danger
potentiel pour le conducteur la marque
au losange évoque un problème lors de
l'assemblage en usine entre le 27
janvier et le 1er mai 2012 ce qui
représente 1736 véhicules écoulés en
France les propriétaires concernés vont
recevoir un courrier en recommandé les
invitant à se rendre chez leur
concessionnaires pour un contrôle d'une
miheure en cas de fuite avéré 2 heures
de réparation seront nécessaires
réparation prise en charge par le
constructeur évidemment le véhicule a
été lancé voici 6 mois il est également
proposé en autopartage dans
l'agglomération cinquantinoise aucun
problème sur ces véhicules n'a été
signalé par
Renault